foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday October 14th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
Tick Tock has helped more than a few
songs become viral Mega hits heat Waves
by glass animals
[Music]
blinding Lights by the weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
and now tick tock's parent company bite
dance is looking to expand its music
streaming business
the Chinese tech company is negotiating
with music labels as it sets its sights
on more than a dozen new markets while
the US isn't included in this next phase
bite Dan says it wanted services to be
available globally the Wall Street
journal's Deputy media editor Jessica
tonkel has been speaking with people
familiar with the company's plans and
she joins us now hi Jessica thank you so
much for coming on the show again thanks
for having me so Jessica bite dance is
looking to expand its music streaming
service across the globe the service
isn't widely available everywhere some
might not even know that it exists what
does its current streaming service look
like now so currently by dance has its
music subscription streaming service
which is called rezo is in three markets
it's in India Indonesia and Brazil and
you can think about it similar to
Spotify it's what we call a freemium
service and that you can have some
limited music listening over just for
free and you have to listen to ads with
that and then there's also a
subscription tier that you can pay for
and the pricing obviously is different
depending on the market do we know why
bite dance became interested in music
streaming in the first place and owning
Tick Tock play a role you know it's a
Natural Evolution given that they own
Tick Tock you know if you go on Tick
Tock you see musical artists break out
all the time it's not a coincidence that
so many of the top songs on the
Billboard charts are also trending on
Tick Tock it's kind of a Natural
Evolution that the company would say hey
maybe we should look into this and try
to keep people on our platform rather
than having them learn about an artist
on Tick Tock and then go to YouTube or
go to Spotify to listen to all their
music
and why is bite dance looking to expand
that service now
I dance and Tick Tock for that matter
are looking at everything that they can
to try to keep people on Tick Tock so
that could be Commerce which we've also
reported that they've been looking at
and doing more with or it's music right
anything that keeps people there longer
is better for the app they don't want
people to spend a few seconds on Tick
Tock and then go anywhere else they want
Tick Tock to be the app that everyone
spends time on
so with those goals in mind what kind of
challenges can we expect bite dance to
face here so there are multiple
challenges when Spotify launched several
years ago it's music streaming service
there was a hunger from the music labels
for some sort of alternative to Napster
at the time today this is a very
competitive market right you have
Spotify you have apple music you have
Amazon you have YouTube so they're
coming into a very competitive market on
top of which they're going to have to
negotiate all of these deals with the
music labels to be able to offer a
subscription music service globally so
that is always complicated you know
people we've spoke to have said that the
music labels really feel that rezo which
is the existing service could do a
better job of getting people to pay for
the service because the music labels
only make money if people are actually
subscribing and so I'm sure this is
going to be a lengthy negotiation I mean
Spotify knows very well how complicated
these negotiations are and you know to
be fair music streaming is not an easy
business in general so they're looking
at this again as a way to keep people on
the app so it'll be interesting to see
kind of what they look at to make this
different than everything else that's
out there speaking of competition you
know you mentioned Spotify Apple music
YouTube Amazon will bite dance and you
know Tick Tock getting into this Market
impact their competitors in any way or
is it just a matter of adding another
player to the field I think that Tick
Tock is in a very strong position if
they can do this all and I think the
thing to watch out for is how is it
integrated with the tick tock app are
you going to be able to see what all
your friends are listening to and click
on it and then subscribe to that artist
music like how embedded is it going to
be how integrated is it going to be how
social will it be there are a lot of
things that they can do if they get it
all right but this is you know I would
say this being a global Service is a far
way out I mean I think this will come
out in a few more markets in the next
few years and then they'll keep adding
to it and adding to it
all right Jessica tonkel thank you so
much for being here with us thanks for
having me again
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our supervising producer is
Chris sinsley and I'm Julie Chang
filling in for our host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
thank you